bonjour à tous merci aujourd'hui on va
parler
pour ma part 2
on appelle les
rien les stats c'est que quand on
interroge les étudiants on a à peu près
50% de d'étudiants qui sont qui se
disent intéressés par l'entrepreneuriat
avoir envie de créer leur boîte mais
après quand on regarde les stats de
création entreprise on se retrouve
plutôt avec un étudiant sur 50
alors qu'est ce qui se passe dans vos
têtes
entre le moment où vous dites pourquoi
pas l moment vous le faites vraiment
mais un certain nombre de choses à
l'environnement familial peut-être les
ressources malheureusement aussi mais
souvent ce sont les mythes
toutes ces idées reçues qu'on a au
travers d'autres qu'on a par rapport à
l'entrepreneuriat et qui peuvent jouer
un rôle dans le fait que vous dites
bah j'ai peut-être avait trouvé un job
quoi finalement ça m'a l'air pas
vraiment pour moi il est ce pour ce talk
là c'est simplement de reprendre ce que
je pense être les quatre vrais aux idées
reçues et puis après vous faire un petit
retour d'expérience pour qu'on fasse un
bout de chemin intellectuelle ensemble
le premier mythe c'est tous les
entrepreneurs sont faits pour être
entrepreneur
ça c'est le premier truc c'est dans la
génétique du bonhomme de devenir
entrepreneur c'est globalement une vaste
connerie pour moi parce que enfin vous
allez le voir mais on ne naît pas
entrepreneur ou devient entrepreneur
parce qu'on a une vision du monde et
qu'on veut la changer ensuite les
entrepreneurs ont la super grosse bonne
idée ça c'est pareil dans les médias
vous allez trouver plein de choses et
plein de gens qui ont des parcours
fantastique et c'est toujours lié à une
idée qui change le monde et ça a l'air
super simple donc vous n'avez pas la
bonne idée elle sort pas nous ne soyez
pas entrepreneur
ça c'est le deuxième mythe le troisième
c'est qu'il faut que tout soit bien
aligner les planètes pour pouvoir
démarrer les gens attendent
certains passent leur vie à attendre le
moment où les choses vont être alignés
elle problème c'est généralement ça
vient un peu tard voir ça vient jamais
et le quatrième
ça c'est peut-être plus positif mais
c'est que l'entrepreneuriat c'est la
liberté et
c'est l'argent assuré avoir à la place
voilà à mon retour d'expérience voilà
les petits conseils que j'aimerais vous
donner vous allez réfléchir ce soir est
à vendre
avant de vous inscrire au registre du
commerce demain matin pour votre
nouvelle boîte qui va déchirer parce que
vous allez tout faire pour
voilà mes petits conseils préparation il
ya un monsieur qui s'appelle benjamin
franklin qui a dit féline tout propre et
un esprit prennent tout faire
vous préparez pas vous casser la gueule
ça c'est sûr le grand message d'espoir
pour tous les gens qui ne se sentent pas
des superhéros
c'est que tout est dans l'anticipation
et la préparation préparez votre boîte
préparez vos réunions préparez vos
speech ça change tout à titre d'exemple
j'ai été un jour dans une réunion et une
négociation sur ce que je trouve être
vraiment un gros contrat pour moi
j'avais tout préparé tous les cas où ça
se passe mal j'arrive dans l'entre-temps
là dans la réunion et le négociateur en
face me dis ok françois on y va j'étais
pas préparé
j'avais préparé en bon français à tous
quel mrd j'ai complètement oublié que ça
pouvait marcher mieux que prévu et la
préparation c'est ça aussi c'est
d'arriver à penser à toutes les
éventualités à les préparer à les
anticiper à trouver des garde-fous à
chaque fois des stratégies associés que
ça marche pas ou que ça marche trop bien
ensuite
osez osez parce que de toute façon vous
allez vous avez percevrez que vous avez
à peu près que 20% des données au moment
vous vous lancez est le reste vous
apprenez en route il n'y a pas de magie
dans ce que font les gens globalement
c'est juste qu'ils prennent un chemin
avec une idée en tête il avance il
arrive à un carrefour et une décision
gauche droite y prennent gauche
il avance peut-être qu'il fallait droite
on verra et puis en plus ils ont après
gauche gauche gauche gauche extrême
gauche puis après plein parce que des
fois il ya c'est pas binaire mais voilà
en gros c'est ça on marche on avance on
apprend en marchant il ya une autre
world inc et qui dit qui dit
l'entrepreneuriat c'est ce se jeter dans
le vide et construire son parachute dans
la descente alors techniquement pensez-y
c'est pas possible
d'où le style d'un penser au parachute
mais qui t'appelle enfilés en sautant
mais au moins vous l'avez donc voilà
oser oser il n'y a pas de problème il
n'y a pas de problème avec le fait
d'oser
il faut oser le troisième beach youssef
enders qu'est ce que ça veut dire déjà
là dedans il ya plusieurs trucs croisé
ya be yourself
vous n'avez pas à devenir quelqu'un
d'autre pour être entrepreneur vous êtes
vous même avec vos qualités vos défauts
mais en aucun cas vous avez à devenir
quelqu'un d'autre
beaucoup de gens qui pensent que
l'entrepreneuriat c'est devenir un
espèce de deux roues
wafa wall street comme on a vu tout à
l'heure où quelqu'un en costard cravate
ou machin et avec une de l'éloquence et
tout ça pas du tout les meilleurs
entrepreneurs sont souvent les gens
plus introverti et qui arrive à laisser
les autres travailler avec eux et
s'exprimer autour de ses clés donc soyez
vous-même n'ayez pas par rapport à ça de
problème vous avez le droit d'être la
personne que vous êtes pour le métier
que vous voulez faire
la deuxième chose c'est beach ou iosafe
j'ai vu énormément de gens se planter
peut-être moi-même inclut d'ailleurs une
certaine manière parce que les gens ne
voient ne sont pas capables de se
regarder dans la glace
en analysant les situations de façon
franche transparente et on passe souvent
à côté de choses et des boîtes qui tombe
parce que les gens n'ont pas vu arriver
à la concurrence parce qu'ils se
disaient qu'ils étaient trop costaud et
des grosses boîtes 1 vous avez des
centaines de milliers d'employés qui
sont retrouvés en balance à un moment
sur des grosses grosses sociétés à cause
de problèmes comme celui là il ya aussi
l'entrepreneur qui est un business model
et qui se dit c'est celui là ce sera pas
un autre et qu'est ce qui se passe va
peut-être qui réussit mais sans réaliser
plein potentiel
parce qu'il faut savoir écouter faut
savoir comprendre autour de soi être
attentif à ce que les autres disent même
s'ils sont pas de votre domaine ya
quelque chose à faire donc dans vos
maturation d'idées d'entrepreneur il est
l'entreprise pensez à ce retour sur
expérience est acceptée le avec humilité
et puis albi tout ça c'est le fait que
le monde est petit et que votre première
boîte elle va jouer sur votre deuxième
boîte ou sur votre prochain job d'après
ou sur d'autres choses et que si vous
semer l'amour et la confiance
vous allez récolter l'amour et la
confiance si vous pensez que tout ce que
vous faites et one chat vous allez
sûrement prendre à un revers un coup de
club
pourquoi pas éventuellement cette
affaire super mal ça va être horrible
et voilà que je me perds dans le sais
j'ai un trou et donc et donc oui soyez
soyez vraiment clean avec vous même avec
les autres parce que ça ça joue
énormément et je pense encore plus dans
l'entrepreneuriat parce que vous
représentez quelque chose à un moment
donné les choses vous dépasse vous êtes
entrepreneur vous êtes patron d'une
société
vous représentez tout les gens qui vous
font confiance qui travaillent avec vous
soit en interne soit en externe vous
représentez vos clients ils ce sont des
choses importantes et vous créez comme
ça des relations ultra honnête ultra
sincère sur le long terme
et ça c'est des choses qui humainement
sont très très intéressante donc au delà
des aspects financiers ou autres
vraiment c'est important ensuite
persévère le great les anglais appellent
ça des great le grid c'est la capacité à
se cramponner je trouve que le terminer
bien tu atteins vraiment l'impression de
rythme comme ça et c'est vraiment ça les
études sont formelles c'est pas les mecs
et les filles les plus intelligents ou
intelligente qui marche mais entreprises
c'est juste les gens qui sont capables
d'avancer de tomber se relever et de
continuer à aller c'est elle avait donc
c'est le marathon de londres ça cette
année
je ne sais pas si vous avez vu cette
vidéo j'en ai eu la larme à l'oeil
elle fait de 30,1 déjà ça c'est la
première larmes c'est que je ferai
jamais de 2002 heures 30 au marathon
mais la deuxième c'est qu'elle fait donc
ses 40 2,1 km à 100 mètres de l'arrivée
elle tombe dans la dernière ligne droite
face aux caméras face au faso à face au
stand d'arrivée elle tombe elle se
relève
elle fait 50 m à leur retour elle est
dans une détresse complètement
incroyable et personnes de l'aide parce
que si le mec là la touche ces invalides
et elle a eu de l'aide extérieure
sa performance est invalide et donc ils
allaient se faire elles continuent elles
avancent elles fini à quatre pattes
elle passe le truc est là elle s'arrête
mais incroyable et c'est ça finalement
cette capacité aussi cas l'entrepreneur
et c'est ça qu'il faut vous disiez c'est
que peu importe vous faites les 42
bornes c'est bien vous faites les
sandales et met ses vieux mais dans
l'ensemble relevé vous avancez et
persévérer une de mes boîtes n'a pas
très bien marché d'autres ont mieux
marché mais j'ai appris tellement dans
mes erreurs
aujourd'hui ce que je suis c'est grâce à
ce que j'ai raté et je sais que c'est
fâcheux les entendu comme vous en faites
jusqu à le vivre personnellement
et je me suis dit ok vas tu poses c'est
super c'est les mecs c'est toujours
mieux d'applaudir un blessé que
d'applaudir un mec et tout réussi mais
la réalité est vraiment là la vérité la
brutalité des événements qui vous arrive
vous apprends plus de choses que ce que
vous réussissez sans avoir forcé edison
avait dit un truc a justement là-dessus
edison vous connaissez comme le mec qui
a fait les lectrices et 5 a fait la
lumière électrique dont clan poule
ces mecs a cofondé et general electric
il a travaillé aussi dans les faits il a
fait pas mal de travaux dans ce qui est
devenu la radiographie
aujourd'hui donc si l'on peut se faire
on voir qu'on se péter la jambe parce
qu'on engueule parachute c'est aussi
grâce à lui et ça c'était avant les
années 1900 comme edison il a dit le
génie c'est 1% d'inspiration et 99% de
transpiration
à méditer ensuite cinq belges ça c'est
classique aussi mais franchement vous
démarrez une boîte c'est pour changer la
vie de deux personnes ou 2 milliards on
vit dans un monde aujourd'hui où tout
est interconnecté où vos concurrents ils
vont pas être du village d'à côté ils
vont être suédois ils vont être suisse
ils vont être chinois australiens et
c'est la vérité c'est la réalité du
business aujourd'hui temps quand vous
créez une boîte quand vous pensez à ce
que vous voulez faire en tant
qu'entrepreneur pensez vraiment à
changer le monde
autant faire grand et ce qui va vous
permettre aussi d'embarquer des gens
avec vous parce que ce que vous allez
faire et vos deux bras
c'est bien vous allez tout donner parce
que vous êtes passionné tout ça mais
aller chercher autour de vous des relais
aller chercher autour de vous de
l'énergie
c'est ce qu'on appelle le viral parfois
ces choses là il faut arriver à les
chercher une communauté à créer une
communauté qui vous dépasse entourez
vous de gens en toute humilité qui sont
plus intelligents vous ont pour certains
c'est peut-être moins difficiles que
d'autres
mais sur le prince le principe le
message est là ça que vous avez réussi à
créer autour de vous une équipe qui
travaille avec vous sur des sujets qui
vous sont importants à vous mais qui
apporte toute leur valeur ajoutée à
autre projet sur une base continue ou
pas que ce soit des clients encore une
fois l'entreprise s'est pas uniquement
quelqu'un qui pense à une idée c'est
quelqu'un qui embarquent et qui inspire
des gens qui travaillent avec eux qui
arrivent à trouver les bons partenaires
et qui crée des liens de long terme
aussi avec ses clients le dernier sujet
je pense qu'on a mis des tartines
aujourd'hui et je pense que ça montre
tout la terra excès et je pense que
c'est le challenge de votre génération
pour le coup je m'inclus je m'inclus
dans votre génération
ouais désolé vous êtes bientôt graduée
donc bon c'est gobeline je pense que le
challenge aujourd'hui c'est de réduire
l'impact de l'humanité sur la planète
ac a été différent dans les dents les
générations précédentes où il fallait
éradiquer des vraies grosses maladie
faire que les gens puissent se relier
d'enfin relier ce voire d'un continent à
un autre ou se parler ça c'était le
challenge d'avant ou se nourrir
maintenant qu'on a fait tout ça et qu'on
est peut-être allé un petit peu loin
dans pas mal de choses l'idée c'est de
rattraper certains excès qu'on a pu
faire
et donc si j'avais un conseil à vous
donner ce serait vraiment d'avancer sur
ce sujet là en tant qu'entrepreneur donc
pour saisie pour ceux qui veulent plus
tard parler de leurs projets j'ai un nom
qui on n'en trouve pas 50 dans
l'annuaire
et sinon l'entreprise pour laquelle je
travaille c'est skyfall donc n'hésitez
pas ou linkedin
et puis on parlera de vos projets et
j'aimerais faire de ce petit 2,50 poser
à 2 à 10% d'entrepreneurs étudiants à
20% par la suite donc n'hésitez pas et
bonne chance à vous
[Applaudissements]